[Applaudissements]
des milliers de manifestants rassemblés
devant le parlement tunisien une
mobilisation pour pointer du doigt ce
que les protestataires dénoncent comme
étant un coup d'état du président kaïs
saïd le lieu du rassemblement est
symbolique le parlement est gelé depuis
plus de trois mois à la suite d'une
décision du chef de l'état désormais
doté des pleins pouvoirs le locataire du
palais de carthage est pointé du doigt
par les protestataires plus tôt on n'est
plus dans un pays démocratique qui a
donné tout ce tout le son de 200 peuple
pendant une dizaine d'années pour la
liberté là on est vraiment dans une
grande prison ou parler devient un crime
parce que monsieur le président ne veut
pas nous entendre et parce que monsieur
le président il est dans son combat
personnel et il n'est pas du tout aller
coûte 200 pas très méchant homme en 2021
on veut un coup d'état un véritable coup
d'état militaire policier c'est l'état
policier qui revient un important
dispositif policier a été mis en place
pour l'occasion un tunis dispositif
destiné à bloquer les accès au parlement
le président kaïs sayyed est de plus en
plus critiqué des élections sont
réclamées notamment par la gauche
tunisienne à taradeau qatar n'a lu
aujourd'hui nous avons une initiative
politique
nous avons un modèle pour vaincre cette
crise ce modèle est basé sur le droit
des tunisiennes et des tunisiens au vote
dans le cadre d'élections présidentielle
et législatives prématurée
en plus d'une crise politique le pays
est plongé dans une crise économique
avec une inflation estimée à 6% et un
taux de chômage de 18 % les tunisiens
veulent voir la situation changer
d'autres mobilisations pourraient avoir
lieu dans les jours à venir